Let's go next to Bobbie from New
Jersey. Bobbie from Jersey, you're on.
Hello, David, how are you? How's it going?
It's going it's going well, Bobby. Thank you.
Thank you, Melissa. My question is, is that
a lot of times a lot of lefty commentators
often cite that things like Medicare for
All has a 70 percent approval rating,
but a lot of times a little consider that
it's support adult and don't know that
that that the support is goes down, whatever.
It's mentioned that there's a tax increase and.
Yeah, I think so. Bobby, I don't want to
interrupt you, but I want to make clear I do,
too. I cover that every time I talk about support
for Medicare for all. So it sounds like you're
talking about other commentators, which I wouldn't
really be able to speak to. But I completely agree
with you. There's very detailed information about
this. The Kaiser Family Foundation has shown that,
you know, the more details you give about
how Medicare all would actually work,
I don't mean scare mongering about government
takeovers and communism, just accurate information
support does go down. So I think it's fair to
say some Medicare for all support is soft or.
Right, but I was all but the point is, is
that a lot of people kind of take polls
too literally and oftentimes don't say
don't know the fine details behind that.
Right. I agree with you. I agree with
you. And that's the case with many more
issues than just Medicare for all. Now, I think,
for example, it's also important, Bobbie, to know
that regardless of whether something is or isn't
popular or is or is not understood by the public,
it might be a good thing or a bad thing. Like
that's also that's a different discussion.
Yes. Do you think sometimes that the the
quantity is the support isn't as important
as the quality of the support? Well, I mean,
the majority should have strong support.
The problem in general with basing whether
something should happen solely on whether it
has support is that the U.S. as a population has
supported really bad things many times in history.
And there are arguably certain things we shouldn't
put to a popular vote. I mean, you look at,
you know, when states vote about should
two gay people be able to get married,
why are we even putting that to a vote like it's
a fundamental, just basic human rights issue? So
I think that looking at popular support for issues
and candidates is one piece of how we analyze the
merits of something. But it's just one piece.
Right.
Thank you, David. All right, my pleasure,
Bobbie, from Jersey. Always great to hear
from you. Why don't we go next to let's
go to LJ from Vegas, LJ from Las Vegas.
What's going on? Hey, David. I'm actually a long
time listener. Glad. Thank you for taking my call.
How are how are things in Vegas? You know,
normally I go twice a year, but I've not
been now because of the pandemic since October of
twenty nineteen. I'm hopeful that I will be back
in October of this year if
all goes well. How is it been.
You know, funny thing, you say that a
lot of my family right now at the moment,
they're currently on unemployment. Thankfully
here we do have a governor that's been taking
good care of us. Yeah, I'm not on unemployment.
I went back after a few months until my job.
The funny thing is, is I actually got to
meet Sam Ceder at one of the conventions you
come out to Vegas for. Oh, really? You were
supposed to arrive, but he said something.
Maybe you're in a doctor's appointment or you
had some kind of I'm not going to get into the
specifics, but and now I had all that.
I had a doctor's appointment in Vegas.
No, no, no, no, no. You were where you
are. Right. But, oh, it's a convention.
When I had when I had the appendectomy. That's
right. I when I had my emergency. Well, I mean,
every every appendectomy, I guess, is mostly
an emergency unless you're going somewhere
where you needed to have preemptively removed,
which sometimes happens when you go on certain
missions to Antarctica. They require preemptive
appendix removal. But no, that's right. I ended
up not making it because it was only a few
weeks after my appendectomy. And I was not
I was not cleared to lift my luggage, so
I couldn't go. That's absolutely right.
Yeah. I was hoping to meet you,
too, because I actually worked
for the convention. You were going to. So I
worked for the Exhibitor Services Department,
so I was super excited to meet you. But then
Sam Theater was like, no, he's not coming out.
And I was like, oh, man, I would love to,
like, shake your hand and said hello next time.
We will hopefully be back in October.
Oh, I don't work for that property
anymore. So as much as I wish were in Vegas,
you ever need someone to show you around,
be more than glad to give you a, you know,
a lift or help you in any way. I love it.
Just one comment I wanted to make, though, and one
thing that I've always wanted to discuss is that
I always feel that here in the United States or at
least globally, how we look like is we're always
defined on the smaller percentage of whatever
percentage that might be of the extremes of,
let's say, the right and the left right. And
I always feel like it is a valid argument to
always constantly keep saying, well, in America,
you have this problem in, you know, all these
issues and everything like that. And it's just the
suppression of the minority that always gets the
the spotlight rather than I'm going to push back.
So, no, I don't know that I agree. Let me push
back a little bit on that. So I think that
there is a difference. So so I guess like
let's imagine would you agree just for our
conversation that we kind of established that
the wacky far right that is sometimes discussed
would be kind of like kuhnen white supremacists,
these people who think Bill Gates is going
to microchip you and that there's no virus
like are we OK with that? Is the the cartoon
of the far right? Oh, yeah, absolutely. OK,
and then are we OK with, like, the cartoon of
the far left as like actual communist socialist
Marxists who want Stalinist USSR or whatever?
Like could we say that's the left caricature.
I as a as a Cuban-American completely
pushed back on that. Of course, that,
you know, that's who I am. But yes, I do agree
that that's the characteristic of the far left.
If you go elsewhere in the world, the U.S. is
known for this socialist left contingent. If
you look at other parts of the world, when people
think about what is the U.S., they see the U.S.
way more as a sort of libertarian, free market
capitalism, unhinged thing. And so while you and I
might say that what I just outlined is typically
seen as the the extreme left by which the U.S.
is judged, the world doesn't look at the U.S. and
think that the so-called socialists or communists
or whatever really have much of an impact.
And the truth is that they don't I mean,
none of them are in power. I think so. I don't
know that I agree with you that around the world,
that's how the U.S. is sort of caricatured.
No, I no, I completely agree with you.
What I'm trying to say is that sometimes
people think that the America itself is
like. What's what's what's a good representation
of this is that we're all gun toting maniacs who
just want to shoot each other. Right?
Right now you're talking that often
is the perception in much of the rest
of the world. You're right now where.
Yeah, well, and, you know, I completely agree
that there are a percentage of people in the
United States who are people who love to
have guns and, you know, what's it called,
use them in any aspect of their life. I do feel
like the overwhelming people who are in the United
States do have a mixed opinion. And I know you've
discussed it with other special guests of yours.
Right. It's not a left right issue. It's more of
like a quadrant. Yes. Yes. You may be liberal on
some things, but you might also be. What is it?
Well, it's it's a authoritarian libertarian.
And then economically left right is often
the kind of four box quadrant that's used.
Correct, and I think that if we fall into the
trap of constantly trying to make everything
left and right, then we're missing the issues.
You know, the grander issue of not everybody
falls into a left right kind of personality.
Agree? Certainly, you know, no argument there.
Yeah. And that's just that's just the comment I
wanted to make, that sometimes maybe we should
stop going from what's what's left doing,
what's the right doing. But what are people
doing specifically in their, you know, aspects and
lives? No argument from me, my friend. Thank you.
All right. Well, Jay from Las Vegas, thank
you so much for the call. We're going to
take a quick break. If you're holding
and wanting to talk to me, don't hang up,
because we're going to take some more
calls right after this short break.